the ugly Republican primary that hasn't
even really started yet is already so
ugly that the next year and a half is
truly going to be insane Donald Trump is
now relentlessly pounding Ron DeSantis
who isn't even running against him yet
and this is a fascinating line of attack
that Trump is starting to use regarding
Social Security and Medicare because
he's effectively attacking Ron DeSantis
from the left while attacking many other
Republicans from the right and of course
it's a reminder that none of this is
about the facts none of this is about
reality this is all about what can I
come up with to insult my opponents if
Trump perceives that it's to his
advantage to say you're not to the right
enough he calls you a rhino if Trump
finds that he actually benefits from
attacking you from the left he'll do
what he's doing with Ron DeSantis and
let's take a look at that and remember
Trump is posting every
single day to truth social about Rhonda
Santos essential Trump posting quote Ron
Des Sanctus voted three times to cut and
Destroy Social Security and increase the
age requirement to at least 70. likewise
he voted to radically cut Medicare he is
a disciple of rhino Paul Ryan what do
you expect this is so funny because
calling Paul Ryan a rhino is a
suggestion that Ryan isn't right enough
but the cutting of Social Security and
Medicare being opposed is almost like
opposing something from the left it's
it's a mishmash unintelligible criticism
but the most important thing is it's
really not super accurate and as I
mentioned last week Ron DeSantis voted
three times for a republican study
committee budget resolution this was in
23rd teen and 2014 and 2015. now those
resolutions failed if they had passed
they were non-binding resolutions to
look at pushing the retirement age of
Social Security to 70. to be crystal
clear with you I'm against that
Ron DeSantis seemed interested in doing
it and it would be a fair criticism but
to say DeSantis voted to cut Social
Security
is a bit of an exaggeration doesn't
matter it's interesting that this is the
line of attack that Trump is taking
whether it's a vote for a cut kind of
depends on what you consider a vote and
what you consider a cut
but Trump's not stopping there Trump
also now attacking Ron DeSantis by
saying yeah Florida is great but it has
nothing to do with you posting a truth
in all capital letters quote Florida was
doing great for many years long before
Ron de Sanctus got there the sunshine
and ocean are wonderful things to have
and then continuing to attack DeSantis
who again remember he's not running yet
with a post that says quote polls show
me doing substantially better against
hopeless Joe Biden then Des Sanctus
would do
an early Forerunner
again would be the 2020 election where I
did much better than in 2016 getting
more votes than any sitting president
in history
that election however was massively
rigged they used the China virus the FBI
Twitter and Facebook
and ballot stuffing in order to cheat
good Republicans won't let that happen
again
get ready for a year and a half of this
stuff and then Trump even more with the
polls saying quote the most recent New
Hampshire poll has me substantially
leading both Ron Des Sanctus and Rhino
Governor Chris sununu who the voters in
New Hampshire are getting very tired of
and unlike his father does nothing to
help the Republican Party Ron's cutting
of Social Security and Medicare would
devastate New Hampshire no way they'd
vote for him now what is the truth of
the polling stuff you know the truth is
that it really varies it is true that
Trump is polling better than DeSantis in
most polls but the degree to which he's
polling better than DeSantis really
varies in one poll it's 25 and another
poll is 21 but in some polls it's Trump
plus eight uh there is a poll that has
DeSantis ahead there's a poll that has
Trump ahead by only two so it really
does vary pretty dramatically that being
said Trump clearly has identified
DeSantis as his number one Contender the
polling certainly coincides with that so
do the CPAC straw poll results which
we'll look at in a little bit more
detail tomorrow but Trump is obsessed
and this is what we can expect for the
next 18 months and remember DeSantis
hasn't even announced yet if and when
DeSantis announces it is going to be
insane
imagine for a second that you try
logging into your email account only to
find that your password was changed an
hour ago and then you get notifications
of activity from your bank and then your
credit cards that is what identity theft
is like and it's a horrible feeling and
we dealt with it at the show not that
long ago but now I have an app called
Aura which gives me much more peace of
mind our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices is go to aura.com Pacman to try
it free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below